hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled engineering the quantum
leap that drug development needs this
webinar is part of the fifth annual drug
discovery and development virtual
conference
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'll now print
present today's speaker michelle
longmire md ceo and co-founder medible
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
dr longmire you may now begin your
presentation
great well thank you everyone for your
time today
and very you know appreciative to be
here and have the opportunity to talk
about something that i'm incredibly
passionate about
which is you know how we enable
effective therapies to reach patients
faster
um i i do wish we had the the
actual solution to the quantum leap but
today it will really be a conversation
about you know what are some of those
strategies that we could leverage
to really accelerate the development of
new therapies
so you know we know that drug
development is a very complex process
i think we're at a point in time
scientifically which is just so exciting
as we've seen with things like the mrna
vaccines
that science
the scientific kind of backbone or
foundation for new therapies is
increasing at an exponential rate
that science has never flourished to the
degree that it is today and the question
really becomes how do we harness these
advancements in basic science to to take
it to the next level which is really
effectively treating human disease
and when you look at kind of the path to
cures or new treatments i would argue
that the biggest bottleneck isn't in the
discovery of new potential molecular
entities or drugs but it's actually the
process by which we can test these
therapies
for safety and efficacy and understand
whether they're actually viable to
improve human health what we call
clinical drug development
and so you know what do we do in a world
where the the opportunities are
increasing at an exponential rate but
our ability to test whether these
therapies are effective is the major
bottleneck
and that's what we'll be talking about
today how do we remove the bottleneck
for clinical development so that we can
more aggressively
get therapies to the many many people
who are waiting for something better
so you know it's pretty interesting when
you look at drug development and where
we are today um just some interesting
facts on this and why we do need this
kind of quantum leap
approach is that today a single drug
cost what it would have been would have
taken to develop 90 drugs 70 years ago
so you know despite the fact that we've
had incredible breakthroughs
in technology over this timeline
clearly if this is the case we're not
fully harnessing what technology brings
to the table to reduce the cost of drug
development
as we know that it takes about 2.6
billion dollars to take a drug from an
animal through human testing to
potentially get an approval so that it
can be leveraged at scale for the
treatment of human disease
and we know that you know we only have
treatments for about 10 percent of human
ailments
so
clearly
we need to think about what can we do to
truly accelerate the development of new
medicines where are the untapped
opportunities to leverage technology and
innovation
in the clinical part of this the inhuman
testing part of this so that we can
really remove that bottleneck
you know in in it's important to take a
look at the barriers that are in the
development process you know we know
cost is one of the major barriers cost
is a barrier because of course we
operate with limited resources and when
costs are extremely high you can only
take so many shots on goal and it it
basically forces drug developers to only
test a certain smaller number of
potential therapies
while there may be many additional
therapies that are unable to be tested
simply because of the cost of loans
we know that the timelines are extremely
long when you look at the entire kind of
phase one through approval process
you're looking at about a 12-year
timeline on average
access to clinical research is an
incredible barrier and we know that this
not only
contributes to the long timelines it
also
basically puts us in a position where
the drugs that we're developing
are often not fully reflective of the
populations living with these conditions
because the participating population is
a much smaller percentage of that total
group and often it doesn't represent the
overall composition from a diversity
perspective of who would receive the
medicine post approval
additionally um
we know that retention is a big
challenge right when we've gone through
all of the work and enable someone to
successfully enroll in a clinical trial
it's extremely disappointing when we're
unable to retain people in the clinical
trials and we have to ask ourselves you
know how can we ensure that the clinical
trial process is not only on par but
ideally superior to health care delivery
itself and what are the right
kind of incentives and opportunities for
us to align from a convenience
perspective to ensure that people will
want to not only enroll but really
remain in the clinical research process
additionally there is a huge disconnect
between research and care
my background i'm a physician scientist
and i trained in dermatology at stanford
one of the leading research centers and
it's interesting even in one of these
you know really world-class research
centers as a physician
clinical trials are not a part of the
way that our physicians are trained and
it's not a part of the standard
healthcare delivery you know even when
these institutions are known for their
research so you can imagine the
disconnect between research and care in
many of the community practices all over
the world
we see an increasing complexity to the
clinical trial protocols and you know
the analysis of this suggests that this
complexity
is not always necessary but that we're
adding additional tests because tests
exist and we may not be focusing on
what's really required in the most
most efficient way to determine safety
and efficacy and often as we are
developing our clinical trial protocols
we're layering in additional tests and
additional and requiring the protocols
to answer additional questions that
actually may not add to the overall
ability to answer the safety and
efficacy question but does add to
patient burden
the regulatory landscape is of course
an important
um an important safety
kind of infrastructure and ensuring that
we're doing what's right for patients
and we're aligning to a way of working
that ensures that safety but also the
regulatory framework can be a limited
limiter to
the innovation and speed that with which
we would ideally pursue the development
of new therapies
and the clinical sites right we know
that clinical sites again myself as a
physician that it's very challenging as
a physician to weave in the delivery of
health care and executing research and
clinical site engagement is one of the
things that we need to solve for when we
look at how we're going to evolve drug
development
so when we look at you know what is the
additional kind of layer around patients
and how we could actually enable
patients
in the science itself to be more
representative it's pretty interesting
when you look at the limited
participation that we see across
different
groups and different demographics so we
know that less than three percent of
eligible participants have access to
clinical trials we know that 11 percent
of research sites fail to enroll a
single patient the number is much
greater when you look at fail to hit
enrollment targets as a whole
we know that you know the budgets for
research in general are going down over
time
but we're still in a position where you
know these drugs and the approval of
these medicines is so critical as we've
seen during the covet pandemic that you
know our ability to get vaccines and you
know really rapidly develop these
vaccinations
it was really what's enabled us to make
progress on our ability to reopen the
world and society and ensure that we're
limiting the damage that kova 19 has had
on human lives
so we need to look at how we're actually
enabling inclusivity in the drug
development process when we have only
three percent of eligible patients we
have to ask ourselves you know what is
the composition of that group even if
it's only three percent one how do we
get that number up and two you know what
is that three percent look like
um when we do you know a double click on
how representative our clinical trials
are we see that this is yet another fail
point in the research efforts
that you know largely clinical trial
participants are caucasian we have
underrepresentation of minority groups
and we often have underrepresentation
of
additional socioeconomic groups
so clearly we need to be able to drive a
drug development process
that is radically different than where
we are today we need to be able to drive
a drug development process that is
faster lower cost more inclusive and
ultimately provides access and retention
that is far beyond the status quo of
what we're seeing today
so how do we get there and again i don't
claim to have you know the panacea but i
do think that innovation
and what we've what we have seen kind of
in terms of technology leverage during
the pandemic highlights some very
promising technologies that we can
leverage to start to solve these
problems
but i would guess that many people in
the audience i would you know who are
familiar with drug development have
heard of decentralized clinical trials
it's really essentially referencing a
clinical trial methodology that removes
the geographic barrier of participation
by enabling more remote and
community-based participation
decentralized clinical trials are not
new
they have been around really for several
decades
but i think until the pandemic there
wasn't a forcing function to test out at
scale some of the cl some of the
decentralized clinical trial
methodologies
what we saw during the pandemic as sites
all over the world were impacted and we
needed to close those clinics
that were mid-flight in the development
of some of the most critical medicines
you know really quickly the
pharmaceutical industry
looked to tech new technologies to solve
this access problem at a time where
there were really no other options
so within the last two years we have
seen acceleration very meaningful
acceleration of the adoption of
decentralized clinical trials where
we're able to provide connectivity for
patients outside of the walls of the
clinical site for some portion of the
data collection
and we're able to provide in many cases
a hybrid model where that data is
collected
at certain points in person but at other
points remotely i would say there's an
additional arm to the decentralized
clinical trial model which is making it
more community centric
where you know we're really
deconstructing the traditional research
site which might um be limited in very
limited in its access point to providing
those
investigators they reach for patients
that actually are within the patient
communities that they're living in
that the patients are living in so this
can look like engagement through retail
pharmacies like a cvs or a walgreens it
look it can also leverage local
laboratories and local imaging centers
versus you know the patient who may live
many hours from stanford and otherwise
would have to drive into stanford to
have all of that testing done so it's
not just about remote access it's not
just about this hybrid in person and
remote but it's also about making
clinical trials not centered around the
site but centered around the communities
that patients are living in so that you
can make those access points often in
person but something more local to where
the participants are actually living
and it's been exciting to see the
adoption of new technologies into
an industry in a process that has
historically been very slow to adopt and
slow down off for good reasons you know
the the tech the barriers are high um i
require me the stakes are high um we
know that the costs investment are
tremendous and in general the
pharmaceutical industry you know is
reluctant to take risk where there's not
a clear benefit
over the last two years we've been able
to
through the adoption of dcts really
start to research where does that
benefit for decentralized clinical
trials exist and i'll and i'll talk
about that research here in a minute and
what some of those outcomes look like
so decentralized clinical trials are a
an important step forward
as we look at solving some of those core
barriers around cost timelines access
potentially site engagement
even also looking at ways in which this
can help us improve patient retention
so when we look at you know what is the
barrier to dct adoption you know we want
to look at how that aligns with the
barriers in the traditional drug
development process and and understand
are we really moving the needle
so the single greatest barrier that's
been identified is really how we do this
across the global regulatory landscape
um where you know as we are collecting
data countries have very different
perspectives on what data can be
collected
remotely or in person and also have
different perspectives on which types of
technologies should be utilized in the
clinical research process
so one of the barriers that remains for
decentralized clinical trials certainly
is how to navigate the global regulatory
framework
including things around endpoint data
collection to data privacy
and these are really kind of local
issues but when you're trying to execute
a global clinical trial protocol you
want to be able to standardize as much
as possible so that your data set is
standardized and when we you know have
different policies and different
approaches being applied to say
france or china it begins to introduce
variation in how that research is
executed so
the the regulatory landscape remains
one of the barriers and hurdles to
overcome
we also need to look at how we can
rewrite protocols in a decentralized
clinical trial world you know there are
things that can be done
that we have been able to show benefit
from such as remote consent remote
data collection how are we actually
adapting our protocols to harness that
benefit
and then understanding you know how we
can enable sites to be leaders in
decentralized clinical trials how does
that really work into the workflow for
the physicians and how do we make this
something that improves site engagement
doesn't actually create another barrier
for the sites themselves
so
there is are no doubt as we look at
decentralized clinical trials and the
opportunity to conduct drug development
in a more convenient and more accessible
way for patients there of course remain
a number of barriers some of which align
with the traditional barriers of drug
development
and others that are unique to
decentralized clinical trials
such as remote endpoint collection
because of this new methodology so
let me
move forward i think it's important
question to ask what do patients think
of decentralized clinical trials
so
patients actually really find that
decentralized clinical trials are an
appealing option now we're early in the
journey of really looking at the entire
scope of the patient experience in dct
because and it's a fairly new
methodology and again has only been
adopted at scale in the last couple of
years but what we do see is that
decentralized clinical trials
can potentially really improve the
patient experience with that said
there's key things to take into
consideration decentralized clinical
trials may only be preferred in a
certain subset of the protocol designs
we need to look at how are we motivating
for participation if you have less
contact with your physician
we need to look at you know are there
concerns and how does this compare from
a dropout rate perspective to a
traditional clinical trial and then
ultimately you know what is the
end-to-end patient journey when we have
less contact at the sites
so more questions that we're exploring
on the patient experience
interestingly when we look at sites and
what they think about decentralized
clinical trials um there are a number of
areas that they're looking critically at
what is the compensation model you know
what does
how does this impact the overall
investment in technology that the sites
need to make
and this is some of the top two areas
that sites find in chat that are
challenging in dcts but interestingly
the areas they find to be
actually less challenging are the time
to implement uh difficulty for
participants to participate does not
seem to be a big challenge and they are
finding that participant safety is also
not among the top challenges for sites
executing dct
so
you know when we look at the challenge
of drug development we look at some of
the traditional barriers and
decentralized clinical trials being
something that essentially had to be
leveraged during the pandemic and now as
we emerge from the pandemic you know
is dct something that we are going to
want to come to continue on the path of
you know in as we look to develop new
and innovative ways to remove those
barriers to the development of new
therapies and i think that
the answer is very interesting and again
still early in the journey but appears
to be a resounding yes and i say that
because we just conducted a large
research study
or analysis with the tuft center for
drug development where we looked at the
net present value of decentralized
clinical trials and we showed that in a
phase three study that we could improve
the overall or we could provide a return
of investment that was 14x greater than
the initial investment made so an roi of
14x and these benefits of dct come from
several key areas and this is again kind
of the inception point of this type of
research but we're showing a reduction
in protocol amendments
we're showing an improvement in patient
retention
and we're showing a reduction in cycle
time that is meaningful um and is in
those the combination of those three
factors is what's leading to a 14x
return on investment in a phase iii
trial that is implementing dcts
now what's interesting about this
research um that it was conducted by ken
getz and joda massey is it looked at
decentralized clinical trial data from
in partnership with medible where we
implemented a modular approach to
decentralized clinical trials so what
this means is that we're taking a
protocol and we're saying you know which
where are the levers that technology
could be applied here to improve
the well essentially to remove the
barriers that were highlighted earlier
how can we improve patient access
how can we reduce the regulatory
barriers through things like reduction
and protocol amendments
how can we improve not only access but
patient retention
how can we improve site engagement
so each one of these clinical trials
that was analyzed it was actually
leveraging a different combination of
technologies that were purpose-built a
fit for that protocol to address some of
those barriers and what's exciting about
that research with the the full kind of
peer-reviewed publication forthcoming is
that that that we are showing we're
meaningfully moving the needle on drug
development by implementing these new
technologies
and again i i wish it was the quantum
leap i wouldn't call it the quantum leap
um
but a 14x you know return on investment
does suggest that there is a meaningful
improvement and that there's also you
know a meaningful potential reduction in
cost
now
the research that was done in
partnership with tufts really was i
think scratching the surface of the
overarching opportunity to look at net
present value of the decentralized
clinical trial approach it was really
looking at
largely the kind of financial return on
investment through those three pillars
that i that i mentioned
cycle time reduction protocol amendment
number of protocol amendments and
retention
the next phase of this research will
really begin to look at that inclusivity
and diversity of the patient population
in greater depth and we'll also look at
ability to reduce cycle time through
other mechanisms um beyond the patient
retention piece of this and i think that
if we look at the impact to diversity
and inclusivity you know that will be a
really important area to compare to
baseline where we know as i mentioned as
i showed in this
earlier slide where we're really
underperforming so the question will
become you know can decentralize
clinical trials really to really provide
an avenue for more diversity and more
inclusivity in clinical trials and if it
does today
that's fantastic if it doesn't how can
we leverage this type of innovation to
achieve those outcomes
so this is kind of the next phase of of
research that medible will be doing in
partnership with
our my company will be doing in
partnership with the test center for
drug development we also recently um
pioneered a partnership with cvs to be
able to provide access through retail
pharmacies with the objective of really
driving more inclusivity and more access
for all types of patients in all
communities
so this will be i think an important
input
to our analysis of the ability for
decentralized clinical trials to
potentially move the needle on some of
those core barriers such as inclusivity
such as access patient retention
areas that we definitely have a lot of
continued work on i would say are in
that global regulatory landscape
today i think there are more unanswered
questions than answered questions when
you look at remote endpoint capture
specifically around primary endpoints
and when you look at the global data
privacy landscape you know there is a
lot of differences in kind of a
prospective approach and regulations
around what data can be collected and
how um and and including things like you
know can you reset your own password
through an application that always that
also collects health information
something that is unfortunately
currently
very very hard to do in geographic areas
like france where there is more
regulatory separation between patient
identifiable information and health
information so really looking at you
know how can we establish a best
practice that's the best for patients
while ensuring those really important
while ensuring very important
additional areas of value for patients
such as data privacy so these are these
are areas that i think the community of
decentralized clinical trials are
actively working on
we we work closely with a group called
dtra or they decentralize clinical trial
research alliance
to help drive um cross-company
collaboration
with the regulators to say you know here
are some of the big barriers let's work
on this together and through that i
think we'll be able to
even um you know really address some of
the barriers that are unique to dct more
head on
so it's exciting time for decentralized
clinical trials it's an exciting time i
think to be in clinical drug development
um you know i think if we fast forward
five years
in our ability to not only leverage
technology but then measure the impact
of that technology which i think is
really important because that should
then evolve your strategy we should see
i believe a really meaningful
improvement in some of the biggest
challenges in drug development and what
excites me the most is to really get to
a point where the development of our
therapies
has a set of data that is really
reflective of the people who will you
know really benefit the most from these
medications once they're brought they're
more widely available once they're
commercialized so i think the
inclusivity piece and the access piece
have
tremendous potential for improvement
through both through the decentralized
clinical trial methodology
um so yep with that i would love to open
it to questions i hope that was a useful
overview of an exciting new area of
innovation in drug development and we'll
go over to the q a
thank you dr longmire for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
let's get started
our first question is are available
technologies really mature enough to
make impact on clinical research
yeah that's a great question and i would
say
before the pandemic you know the
utilization wasn't at the scale that it
is at now um metabol our company who's
one of several you know in this area has
now conducted over 300 decentralized
clinical trials and in the definition of
decentralized there would be utilization
of um one of the core technologies to
provide remote access to one of the key
parts of the clinical research process
so it could be telemedicine it could be
remote consent it could be you know the
use of remote data collection
via
outcome assessments or connected sensors
but with over 300 that was the data that
was leveraged for the test evaluation of
net present value of dct
and that's where we showed a 14x
improvement um or 14x
roi on a the investment for a phase 3
clinical trial so it is um i would say
we're at a point where we can say yes
these technologies are mature
and that we have a pretty strong
indication of what that investment will
provide back for drug developers
great thank you
our next question is what do you think
will be the biggest area of impact that
technology will have on the life cycle
of drugs
i think that the biggest impact will
really be around this inclusivity piece
you know when you look at a drug like
vioxx right and you have to ask yourself
well how did we get to a state where
once a drug was commercialized we
discovered that you know it was very
dangerous in some patients i think that
it's clear that our drug
development process needs to have
inclusivity and it needs to be inclusive
around different demographic and um and
ethnic and racial groups but it also
needs to begin to take into
consideration additional um layers that
we may not be considering such as you
know additional kind of um
additional layers around genetic
diversity that i think isn't always
reflective through what would be more of
a phenotypic categorization you know of
different types of people and i think
when you combine you know those elements
and you look at decentralized clinical
trials we should really be able to
develop a more robust
set of research participants that are
reflective of the people who will
ultimately benefit the most from those
medications and should also help us
understand in the research process who
are the people that benefit the most
from this medication so to me i think
that the primary
area of benefit one of them will
certainly be i well one of the areas
that we're really looking to you know
move the needle on is around inclusivity
and diversity of clinical child
participation
with the goal of developing
you know
therapies that are more effective at
scale
great
next question
where do you think innovation and
clinical research will be in the next
five years
well you know i really envision
especially as we make partnerships with
companies like cvs
that research will really be a clinical
will be a care option and i you know i
think we're trying to build a world
where you know when you think about your
own life and you're like okay you know
i'm struggling with psoriasis or i'm
struggling you know with um you name it
parkinson's disease people have a very
easy path to new therapies that are in
the development development today
i think right now people are interested
in therapies that are in development but
it's very unclear how we they get access
and i would say that there's an entirely
larger group of people who aren't even
aware of this as an option so you know
in five years
i believe we could build a world where
everyone thinks about investigational
treatments as a first line option or
certainly an option for that and that
would be accessible and where they would
have information at the tips of their
fingers and be able to enroll in
clinical trials to access those
medicines you know just as easy as it is
to go to the pharmacy and pick up your
asthma medication
great thank you
um next question
what what is the role of organ on chip
for decreasing the cost and increasing
of speed of drug discovery in a
practical manner
yeah the organ on chip concept i think
is really really exciting you know this
is basically saying
you know
how can we create
synthetic models
of human biology where you really reduce
then ideally you remove a lot of the
safety risk because you're testing the
both the safety and the efficacy in this
kind of synthetic organ model
um
you know coming out of stanford where we
worked in i worked in a lab that you
know really leveraged
you know models synthetic models or you
know biological models of human skin i
see this has tremendous process i think
i mean
tremendous potential i think in certain
areas it's it's a bit farther away
from a
from
a real world application
but there are certain areas like in
dermatology where i think we'll see this
model leverage sooner than later
all right thank you
next question
to reduce the time spent on drug
discovery can some of the phases be
merged to achieve this
yeah this is this is a really important
question and you know when you look at
areas
of of
need where say people do not have other
therapeutic options
you know it it makes a lot of sense to
start to converge the the phases because
you really want to reduce the timelines
and you want to provide the therapy as
an option as soon as you know ideally
you have any any real data around
efficacy if there's really no other
option or if patients say hey i know
that fxe data isn't there yet but again
i have no better option
so
there has been um a movement to provide
access to these therapies with consent
at say a phase 2b um where there may be
no other options and certainly some of
the more innovative um protocol or drug
development models will begin to to
merge phase one and phase two or phase
two and phase three so it's an important
thing to be able to do in certain
therapeutic areas and certainly it's
something we're seeing being done more
often
great thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
where do you see
pharmacogenomics playing a role in
clinical trials yeah i think you know
again when when asked about where will
we be in five years i think you know we
need to not only provide
access to patients that you know
ensuring we have the right diversity
from a type
where we're also really taking genotype
into consideration
so you know genotype is
in our you know the underlying kind of
genomic diversity is far greater than
what we have you know from a phenotype
perspective so i think this is going to
become an increasing you know an area of
increasing interest
how genotype relates to safety and
efficacy
and it becomes a great tool to then
measure where we could apply those
therapies you know is yet kind of almost
another diagnostic to say okay we know
this genotype
really responds well to the drug
or this genotype there's more safety
risk
it provides another lens
around you know who would best benefit
from these therapies so i think that
it's going to certainly be a key pillar
of drug development in the next couple
of years
thank you dr longmire for your
informative presentation
um
do you have any final comments for our
audience
no you know just excited to have the
time with you today um if you're you
know certainly if you want to visit the
medieval website we have a white paper
on the study i was referencing from
tests i think it's probably one of the
most robust analyses of decentralized
clinical trials to date unfortunately
the white paper has a fairly limited um
look into the data but the peer-reviewed
paper is forthcoming and would be you
know happy to provide anyone that is
that is that's available if you want to
email me michelle mediball.com but i'm
excited to have the opportunity to speak
with you today and thank you for your
phenomenal questions
well thank you again dr longmire for
your time today and your important
research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until february 2024
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye